lawmakers on capitol hill are etching
closer to a deal on a new covet relief
package after five months of delays
it would provide aid for everything from
housing to health care to education
the federal reserve warned yesterday
that americans still
need help because of to economic
recovery is still
very uncertain nancy cordes is covering
the talks
the relief bill that's nearly done is
aimed at helping
everyone from health care workers to
students to the unemployed
it's a roughly 900 billion dollar
package with a stocking stuffer for most
americans
in the form of a six to seven hundred
dollar stimulus check
direct assistance to working people and
working families
is in the bill the bill also contains
rental assistance food assistance money
for schools and vaccine distribution
and 300 billion in relief for small
businesses
there's also about four months worth of
federal jobless benefits
300 dollars per person per week down
from
600 this past spring it would also
suspend student loan payments
and extend the eviction moratorium i am
one of those people
i cannot back pay all of my rent i will
lose my apartment in january if they
don't pass any relief this week
stephanie freed is a production
electrician in new york city
who last worked in march it must happen
this week it absolutely must
but it is disappointing that it has
taken five months
months of congressional gridlock have
taken a toll
retail sales fell last month right at
the start of the holiday season
and weekly jobless claims are inching
back up
federal reserve chair jerome powell has
been urging congress to act
and did so again yesterday i think would
be very good for the economy if we did
get something soon congressional leaders
insist they are this
close to cementing the deal and
releasing a bill but they're running out
of time
they want to attach it to a government
funding bill
and government funding runs out tomorrow
leading to more questions gail about
why they waited this long to negotiate
in earnest
in the first place i know and nancy as
you know this close
doesn't matter when it's not done oh boy
absolutely
thank you very much